It seems to be that in the Korean Peninsular
the drums of war seem to constantly be rumbling.
Alright, so it is true, that this area was
not known for its peacefulness, but the kind
of tension that the area has been feeling
recently has not existed for some time…
The United States, a country which already
had 30,000 soldiers deployed in the area,
has also deployed several aircraft carriers,
heavy bombers, and even an advanced anti-missile
system in South Korea.
It is so advanced that China has even considered
it a threat to their own security.
(“China tells US to remove anti-missile
THAAD system from South Korea amid spying
fears”, The Independent)
North Korea, on the other hand, keeps carrying
out new tests with ballistic missiles and
progressing with its nuclear programme.
It seems that North Korea doesn't really care
about all the international legislation about
nonproliferation and nuclear testing.
Japan and South Korea are feeling understandably
tense.
They want to know what to do, what decisions
to make, step by step, in order to stop the
growing threat that Kim Jong-Un represents.
We already told you in a previous video here
at VisualPolitik about how Japan is seriously
considering putting an end to the pacifist
nature of the Japanese Constitution.
And it even seems right not that even in Beijing
they have had enough of Pyongyang…
(China reportedly sent 150,000 troops to North
Korea's border.
)
If this story were a movie, you’d probably
leave the cinema thinking that the writer
had taken too many creative liberties…
But, what is really happening in this region?
What can we actually expect?
Well, that’s what we are going to be talking
about in this Visual Politik video, but before
we get into all of that, let’s get some
perspective.
(WHERE ARE WE?
AND HOW DID WE GET TO THIS SITUATION?)
North Korea is some sort of nightmare from
the past, it is a country still living in
the Cold War, a country with one of the most
totalitarian governments in the world, and
along with all of that, it’s also one of
the poorest countries on the planet.
(According to the United Nations, 2 out of
5 North Koreans suffer from undernourishment)
But Kim Jong-Un,the guy who controls the country
with an iron fist, doesn't seem to give a
damn about any of that.
So, it is estimated that Pyongyang started
to develop its nuclear programme around the
1980s, and since then, there have been a few
key situations which have sped up this process:
The first was the fall of the Soviet Union
in 1991, then came George W Bush´s incorporation
of North Korea into the so-called “Axis
of evil” in 2002, and then there was the
coming to power of Kim Jong-Un in 2011.
We could say that, every time the regime felt
threatened, they decided to accelerate the
process, but we’re going to discuss that
later in the video...
(The issue is, today, it is estimated that
North Korea holds from 10 to 20 nuclear weapons
and, according to Rand Corporation, if it
doesn´t stop, the North Korean programme
could accumulate around 100 nuclear bombs
by the year 2020.)
But, wait, because this isn't the end of the
story.
For now, the technology used in this country
is… well… pretty basic.
It is based on old designs from the Soviet
Union, so the bombs they have developed up
until now don’t work brilliantly.
And THAT is why Pyongyang is now obsessed
with two things:
On the one hand: attempting to miniaturize
the bombs so they can be placed in missiles.
And on the other hand: developing ballistic
missiles capable of attacking targets that
are thousands of miles away.
And, hey, the last tests they have conducted
indicate they are probably making some important
advances.
Many analysts, including the Intelligence
Services of South Korea and The United States,
have in fact considered that North Korea is
already capable of weaponizing short and mid-range
missiles with nuclear warheads, which could
allow them to reach South Korea and Japan.
And that is not all, it seems clear that,
if the programme doesn’t stop, in a few
years, North Korea will be capable of attacking
the United States of America with ballistic
missiles.
This would be a significant strategic leap
forward for North Korea.
And that, dear friends, is a red line which
is causing the Pentagon many, many headaches.
So now you might be wondering: Hasn’t the
United States done anything to stop this country?
And, well, the truth is they have tried almost
everything.
(THE U.S. STRATEGY)
For years, the United States and South Korea
have tried to persuade Pyongyang to abandon
their plan of developing nuclear weapons,
and they didn't have any problem taking out
the checkbook in order to do this…
(In the early 90s, in 1994 to be specific,
Bill Clinton signed the agreement framework
by which North Korea commited to cancel his
military plans in exchange for a generous
fuel help from the United States as well as
assistance to build two nuclear reactors for
civilian use.)
With this agreement, North Korea obtained
the energy they needed to develop their economy.
As for South Korea, besides giving a huge
amount of humanitarian aid, they also committed
to boost and finance North Korea’s economic
development programmes.
It all seemed to be going well… for a while…
However, it all fell to pieces in 2002 when
George W. Bush found out that Pyongyang had
been fooling them.
In secret, North Korea had kept developing
its nuclear programmes for military purposes.
After more negotiations, they reached a new
agreement and Bush’s administration restarted
their aid program and lifted sanctions…
but a year later, Pyongyang reneged on the
deal.
Despite all this, Barack Obama decided to
try yet again:
In February 2012 they reached a new agreement:
North Korea cancelled the nuclear programme
and the United States restarted (once again)
economic aid.
This time, Pyongyang broke the agreement only
6 weeks later.
Alright, so we get the picture.
Now you might be wondering: Why are they so
insistent on having nuclear weapons at all?
(WHAT ARE THEY LOOKING FOR?)
The regime of Kim Jong-Un is pretty set on
developing more advanced nuclear weapons,
and the international community is going to
have to get used to the idea that this is
not something that they are going to abandon.
But that still leaves us with the question:
Why?
Well, first of all, because they think nuclear
weapons are essential for their survival.
Pyongyang knows that, with nuclear weapons
around, no foreign power, especially the United
States, would dare to intervene in the country.
When the United States invaded Iraq, North
Korean leaders were paying attention.
For them, the first mistake Saddam Hussein
made was not having nuclear weapons and other
WMDs.
They thought the same thing when Gaddafi’s
regime fell.
Libya had voluntarily cancelled its programme
for the development of WMDs a few years earlier.
So, the North Korean leaders think, and, honestly,
they are probably right, that nuclear weapons
are the best guarantee to their staying in
power.
Further, the sales of nuclear weapons technology
is one of the main sources of foreign currency
coming into the country - currency needed
so the elite can maintain their standards
of living.
Since the fall of the Soviet Union, North
Korea has become one of the main exporters
of missile equipment, technology and components.
(“US seizes North Korean ship taking missiles
to Yemen”.
The Independent)
Also, indications are that North Korea has
sold nuclear technology to Iran, and advised
Syria in the construction of the nuclear reactor
that Israel bombarded in 2007.
(“Israel strike 'targeted Syrian nuclear
reactor”.
The Telegraph)
It is precisely this risk of proliferation
which is why the United States is trying so
hard to stop North Korea.
The other reason is, of course, to try to
prevent this country from being capable of
threatening the United States with a nuclear
attack.
So now we come to China.
What does China think of all of this?
(CHINA)
One thing is certain: if it weren't for China´s
support, North Korea would have never developed
its nuclear programme.
And it is not just the technological part
that we are talking about, or the support
to avoid international penalties: it’s also
the money.
“China accounts for more than 90% of North
Korea's total trade” DailyNK
In other words, without the support of Beijing,
this country would have collapsed a long time
ago.
However, there are some signs which tell us
China is a bit tired of so much provocation,
and they are not happy about those nuclear
missiles either.
It could be said that, for Beijing, Pyongyang
is now a burden now that China has to deal
with as it attempts to gain influence and
leadership in international politics.
“China takes the driver's seat on free trade”.
DW
Some analysts have even suggested that Beijing
might be losing control over the government
of Pyongyang which is now self absorbed by
their new nuclear capability.
Importantly, for the first time, in November
of 2016 China agreed to completely stick with
the international sanctions being levelled
against North Korea.
Besides, in the last months, China has forbidden
North Korean coal imports and gas exports,
and, well, the international community is
holding its breath, that is a significant
punishment for the Kim Jong-Un regime.
And there is more: International relations
between these two countries is not at its
best point...
In fact, since Kim Jong-Un came to power power,
no top-level bilateral meetings have taken
place and there are less and less official
visits between the countries.
So, is Beijing really changing its relationship
with Pyongyang?
(THE ROAD TO A SOLUTION?)
It is still soon to know, but don't be fooled.
For the time being, China is not going to
let North Korea fall, which is still an ally
for them in the region.
At least, not until they have serious reasons
to do so...
And that is a key point to understand if we
want to find a solution to this crisis:
China needs to be persuaded to try and make
Pyongyang put an end to this, to cancel their
nuclear programme and carry out real reforms.
But that won't happen under the current set
up.
That is why many experts think it is time
for the United States to withdraw from Korea
and consider the dismantling the anti-missile
system, and perhaps consider some economic
compensation as well.
It’s also important that China understands
that the current situation might lead South
Korea and Japan to pursue an arms race, as
well as the option of developing their own
nuclear weapons.
So, now we’ve told you our opinion here
at Visual Politik, and we’d love to know
what you think, click here if you want to
leave your opinion in this quick survey.
What do you think Trump´s Administration
should do?
Do you think Should North Korea put an end
to its nuclear plans?
Should they even be threatened with war?
So I really hope you enjoyed that video, if
you did please do click the 'subscribe' button
and stay tuned for our new videos every Monday
and Thursday.
And don’t forget to check out the Reconsider
Media Podcast - they actually provided the
voice for this video that isn’t mine!
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.